welcome to the david patten show i am
benjamin dixon filling in for david
pakman once again david is away and
we'll be back on next week I hope
everyone is enjoying this time than we
have together it's been great so far
let's jump right into the news the
unbelievable op-ed that came out from an
anonymous senior official in the White
House published by the New York Times
now the New York Times gave a disclaimer
at the beginning of the article saying
that this is something that they
normally would not do but they have
verified the source they know who the
individual is and they felt that this
perspective was worthwhile enough to
publish underneath a an anonymous source
as an anonymous source so I want to read
a couple of quotes from this article and
then we can get into all all of the
fallout shortly thereafter that but here
a couple of quotes from the article that
stand out and this is what it says quote
the dilemma which he president Trump
does not fully grasp is that many of the
senior officials in his own
administration are working diligently
from within to frustrate parts of his
agenda and his worst inclinations I
would know I am one of them to be clear
ours is not the popular quote-unquote
resistance of the left we want the
administration to succeed and think that
many of its policies have already made
America safer and more prosperous but we
believe our first duty is to this
country and the president continues to
act in a manner that is detrimental to
the health of our Republic that is why
many Trump appointees have vowed that we
to do what we can to preserve our
democratic institutions while 14 mr.
Trump's more misguided impulses until he
is out of office wow I mean this is this
confirms again I think we talked about
this the other day with Bob Woodward's
book this this article echos the book
and simultaneously are similarly as I
described in that review of his book
that this is not shocking
it's now
surprising but it still blows your mind
I don't know how it manages to do all of
that at the same time don't ask me it
just it just does this like this article
you know I don't know if you've seen the
mean we're the guys that effect because
it clearly demonstrates that we aren't
the ones who are off those of us who
have been warning about Donald Trump
those of us who have been saying that
this this guy is a madman
that he has no capacity to lead this
country simultaneously being told by the
propaganda machine of Fox News and the
conservatism in general that the
president is is up to the task and he
has great accomplishments all the while
the senior officials in the White House
are having to pull stunts to keep Hill
from destroying the world now there's a
lot to be said about this individual you
know he referenced or he or she we don't
know who they are there's a lot of
speculation but there's there's there's
a lot to be said about this individual
attempting more of an administrative
coup I believe I saw jeet here from the
Washington Post use that phrase an
administrative coup instead of directing
the country towards a 25th amendment
solution right in a way this person who
is attempting to be brave with this
anonymous op-ed is it's very cowardly
and that's a you know that's a word that
I've seen across the internet in
response to this article that it's
cowardly I don't think it's cowardly for
them to hide behind being by being in an
anonymous source that's not what's
cowardly to me necessarily I haven't
think about it more before I can give
that any you know believe that I think
it's cowardly that they would rather do
this they would rather sabotage Donald
Trump's efforts thankfully yes grateful
for it in a sense that they are stopping
him from destroying the world but
they're not willing to go the step of
getting him out of office at least
temporarily visibly the 25th amendment
that to me is what's coward
now there's a lot of responses to this
across the web but I want to read the
response obviously from Donald Trump and
this is what he had to say on Twitter he
said quote does the so-called senior
administration official really exist or
is it just the failing New York Times
with another phony source if the gutless
anonymous source anonymous person does
indeed exist the times must for national
security purposes turn him or her over
to the government at once the president
wasn't finished take a look at this
video of the president if the failing
New York Times has an anonymous
editorial anonymous we're doing a great
job the poll numbers are through the
roof our poll numbers are great and
guess what nobody is going to come close
to beating me in 2020 because of what
we've done and the president still
wasn't finished because he tweeted once
again afterwards he said this simply
treason question mark yeah there's a lot
of trees in this this article isn't one
I want to read some responses from a
couple of friends well he's one of them
are a friend of mine Sam cedar of the
majority report he said this on Twitter
quote this New York Times op-ed is the
first salvo in the predictable attempt
by the GOP / conservatives to make the
now increasingly expendable Trump not of
them don't buy it
President Trump doesn't exist were it
not for what these people built that is
something I absolutely can agree with
because as you read this article it
gives you this sense that that there's
actually a functioning party a
functioning group of individuals in this
administration who are doing the valiant
thing and they give you you know I
conjures up thoughts of episodes of
whatever series that focused on the
president and and the staff that's
trying to make sure the presidents do no
no no no all of these people were
complicit with getting Donald Trump into
power and now they are all going to be
held accountable for what he's doing in
power now mind you I'm grateful that
they're stopping World War three
continue to do that but that's the
minimum that's the very
least you know that's the least that you
could do getting us saddled with the
maniac like Donald Trump this is what
Chris Hayes of MSNBC had to say he said
quote the op-ed is an attempt to take
out an insurance policy for the GOP and
conservatism if and when things get much
much worse it's a very public hedge
meant to preserve the reputation of the
GOP his entire political and governing
class again pretty much echoing what Sam
cedar had already said finally jeet here
I guess three times it's confirmation he
said this quote this should be a
reminder that the real resistance is not
amongst White House officials writing
anonymous op eds or even at John
McCain's funeral
the real resistance is in popular
organizing organization protest strikes
and electioneering aimed at changing the
status quo and I agree with those
sentiments so you know this article is
fascinating if I had more time maybe on
my pocket pass cut the podcast I would
delve into the question of presidential
authority and presidential power and
other times in history where we've seen
an administration refused to do what the
president asks we see something similar
but definitely not as drastic as I
mentioned yesterday with Rahm Emmanuel
refusing Rahm Emanuel and Timothy
Geithner refusing to implement President
Obama's wishes to break up the banks
we've seen this with the Cuban Missile
Crisis where it was really JFK against
his administration trying to get them to
do what he said to do but then I'm also
reminded I guess I'm talking about
anyway I'm reminded of Franklin
Roosevelt who had checks and balances on
his staff he had people throughout his
administration that would rat on the
other person because he knew this is how
administration's work and so he was able
to get things done by not having anyone
in authority that he didn't have
somebody secondary who would who would
basically rat them out to him so this is
a really good article for an academic
exercise and I would do that on my own
show I probably would
professor friends of mine to actually
talk about that aspect of it
but in terms of the political news cycle
this is madness